bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de samsung qui s'apprête à sortir d'ici
quelques temps un tout nouveau produit
après l'échec de la galaxy note 7
l'année dernière il devrait sortir la
galaxy note 8 cette année et là pour le
coup l'enjeu est énorme
il s'agit pour samsung de montrer
qu'elles sont capables cette fois-ci de
sortir ce produit sans aucun défaut un
défaut qui leur a coûté très très très
cher sur la version d'avant autant
samsung a fait un carton en début
d'année avec son samsung galaxy s suite
il ya très très bien marché maintenant
il est temps de continuer de garder
cette position de leader ce tout cas
l'enjeu c'est de faire oublier l'échec
cuisant de la note 7
alors il ya des infos et des rumeurs qui
deviennent de plus en plus persistantes
on arrive à voir à quoi va ressembler 7
samsung galaxy note 8
alors elle devrait très clairement
s'inspirer des grands points qui ont
fait le succès qui font d'ailleurs
toujours le succès du samsung galaxy s
suite à commencer par son écran là on
devrait avoir un écran carrément géant
6,3 pouces en super amoled
je vous laisse imaginer la dalle elle
devrait être énorme d'une super qualité
et toujours sur un écran infiniti bord à
bord ça c'est vraiment un élément
central qui a fait le succès du galaxy s
fait qu'on connaît aujourd'hui on parle
bien d'un écran 6,3 poussant savoir que
le galaxy note 7 avait un écran 5,7
pouces comme je le disais devrait
reprendre les points principaux qui ont
fait le succès du galaxy sii a commencé
par un double module photo situé à
l'arrière avec mode portrait zoom
optique et on devrait également avoir
une résolution 12 millions de pixels
pendant longtemps une rumeur était
persistante on croyait que lecteur
d'empreintes digitales on a pu se situer
directement sur l'écran
d'ailleurs des rumeurs qu'on retrouve
pour l'iphone 8 1 qui sortira très
prochainement a priori il n'en sera rien
pour cette note suit on devrait
retrouver soit un lecteur d'empreintes
digitales sur le côté de la fable est
soit à l'arrière comme on peut retrouver
sur le galaxy s suite
côté processeur on dit retrouver le
processeur de qualcomm le snapdragon 835
il devrait y avoir 6 giga de ram et 64
giga de stockage qu'on pourrait monter
avec une microsd jusqu'à 256 giga
et devrait également y avoir un style et
notamment pour faciliter la prise de
note une prise casque de l'usbc est a
priori du bluetooth 5.0 à savoir que le
galaxy et suite a été le tout premier
smartphone à être équipé du bluetooth
5.0 dans ce domaine il est très clair
que samsung va continuer à se
positionner sur cette technologie qui
permet d'avoir des communications
beaucoup plus rapide entre différents
appareils côté batterie ils ont joué la
sécurité on sait que c'était vraiment la
raison de l'échec cuisant du nobs est là
on devrait retrouver une batterie 3300
milliampères heures il devrait également
y avoir aussi un scanner d'iris avec une
caméra située à l'avant pour
déverrouiller plus rapidement et bien
évidemment bigby sera de la partie avec
un bouton dédié directement sur la
tranche de l'appareil
un appareil qui devrait quand même faire
un certain prix qu'on devrait retrouver
aux alentours des 1000 dollars alors
normalement cet appareil devait être
annoncée au mois de septembre mais a
priori le calendrier aurait été revu le
produit devrait être annoncée dans la
deuxième quinzaine du mois d'août
à new york il ya deux raisons
principales à ça la toute première c'est
de pallier à la baisse des ventes du
samsung galaxy et suit effectivement il
ya eu un début qui a très bien
fonctionné depuis le mois de juin les
ventes seraient en baisse va donc
falloir réagir rapidement pour booster
le chiffre d'affaires de samsung en
avançant légèrement la sortie d'une
hotte suite le deuxième point pour être
effectivement décidé de couper un petit
peu l'herbe sous le pied apple avec
l'annoncé au mode septembre normalement
de son
un iphone 8 alors il est très clair que
ce ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
produits mais on sait que les budgets
liés à la itech ne sont pas extensibles
dans les foyers même pour des usages
professionnels
donc il est très clair que si samsung
arrive à convaincre et à prendre les
budgets pour lui viendra forcément un
petit peu moins pour apple comme je
voulais dit là l'enjeu est très très
très clair pour samsung
il s'agit de faire oublier le fiasco du
galaxy note 7 pour mémoire un lieu comme
un programme de rappel de produits et
les pertes sont estimées à 5 milliards
d'euros c'est juste colossal ce coup ci
c'est très clair samsung n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur
une autre rumeur fait état d'un probable
écran 4 cas à savoir si ce sera le cas
oui ou non même si on a un écran 6,3
pouces avec une dalle en super amoled de
la 4k
c'est pas sûr toujours est il que s'il
ya une dalle en cas de casse qui
pourrait être vraiment intéressant c'est
pour utilisation pour la réalité
virtuelle
ce que je reproche à la réalité
virtuelle chez samsung c'est lorsque
vous posez votre casse votre s7 ou votre
la suite directement sur votre
smartphone c'est que vous voyez quand
même les lignes vous voyez le pixel
c'est pas terrible
si on arrive à avoir une résolution 4k
on n'aura plus ce problème ce sera
beaucoup plus immersif beaucoup plus
réaliste et l'expérience sera beaucoup
plus intéressante
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ce samsung galaxy note 8
un produit qui devrait arriver très
prochainement rester connecté on en
reparlera quand samsung aura fait son
annonce on aura probablement d'autres
informations là-dessus
j'espère que le produit sera la hauteur
et que cette fois ci il n'y aura pas
déçu merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo si
elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas mais ça je
le pousse à vous abonner à la chaîne et
moi je vous dis à bientôt salut
[Applaudissements]